guys were here at Kapow comic-con in
London tell us who you are and what
you're doing here everyone is recognized
except me it was like who are you okay
let's go down the line who you
I'm scarecrow Riddler from Arkham see
poison ivy Harley Quinn brilliant and so
what are you doing here so far today
well I should've stopped wandering
around checking out scenes first time
we've been to this college so it's just
checking out what it's light and sort
signal decent costumes because it's
loads of good costumes today
who've you seen so far do you think
that's a really good costume gosh
there's a really really good cat when
walking around there's also really
really good black cats also seen a
couple of really good Green Lantern's
downstairs as well so we're gonna have
to go in grab a photo at them soon and
what are you looking forward to doing
here today and today I've just looking
around to be honest there's nothing in
particular we've got no plan that ways
just to look around and have fun oh so
do you go to a lot of these kind of
comic conventions yeah we do
he's nominee more recognizable as Doctor
Who and we all do various different
costumes and she's more recognized as a
peg doll from Doctor Who and so it's
this is his first time with in a whole
group costume costume de comic form yeah
so what kind of comics do you like apart
from how you're dressed today
the latest marvel x-men vs. Avengers
very good yeah I think it's something to
wait for a long time to do that so
that's been really good a lot the
independent stuff you just I've seen
loads today I think that's really good
they love the artwork nothing else I'm
looking forward to when the Star Trek
and Doctor Who combo comes out that
could be that can be quite interesting
how about over here I'm gonna be confess
I'm more of a Marvel girl than a DC girl
I will I will confess and same thing
Marvel versus Avengers vs. x-men
exactly the same same as scarecrow said
with the Star Trek Doctor Who
combinations going to be very good so
thinking about the movies now what do
you think of the latest marbles Avengers
Assemble perfect twenty years so I've
come from Buffy Angel and just that I
mean I love serenity and like Firefly
and that all those in dollhouse and then
but it's just amazing that he's done it
and he's something so well because it
was like oh he's not going to do well
because like you know one really gets
serenity that well you have to kind of
know the Firefly then whatever I'm like
he's just done an amazing job having
having the whole background of because
they've all had their own films then
just bring them together and then having
the other characters like you know Nick
where we don't know him that well we
don't know Hawkeye and black widow that
well but bringing them together it's
just he's just my god
and they looking forward to Avengers 2
there which has been a now all the
versions are coming out the second ones
coming in like the Thor and the Captain
America just to seeing them evolving to
be really good then you've got the whole
like it's just weird and gonna do the
second one because who can you it's got
to be it because he's a fan you've got
to have a fan doing it and that's how
they've done it that's why it's gone so
well completely agree with you so send a
message out that we won't just read and
for goodness too long with Doctor
Strange and was miss Marvel yeah a lot
more guys fantastic to meet you you all
look amazing
kudos on the costumes thanks for talking
that's cool
you